[Subtitles: Bastiaan Cnossen]
Usually, I don't think notation in
math matters that much.
Don't get me wrong,
I enjoy a bad notation rent as much as the next guy,
and there are clearly a few simple
changes to our conventions
that could speed up learning
for math students everywhere.
But at the end of the day, notation, good or bad,
it's just not the point of math.
Even the most carefully designed symbols and syntax
will fail to capture the underlying visual
that constitutes understanding.
So I figure it's better to just spend
time focusing on that underlying essence
and let the symbols just be what they
are in peace.
But that said, when unintuitive notation
actively stalls the gears of learning
this position on the matter hardens
up a little bit.
In particular, I'm thinking of one threesome of syntax,
which, when you stop and think about it,
is an egregious source of friction
in math education everywhere.
If you take the fact that 2 multiplied
by itself 3 times equals 8 for example,
we have three separate ways
to explain that relationship:
2^3 = 8, with a superscript;
∛8 = 2,  with a spikely radical symbol;
and log₂(8) = 3,
which we write using the word 'log' itself.
What the hell do these three ways of
writing the same fact have to do with each other?
Making up syntax for a
concept is fine, but don't do it in three
completely different ways for the same
concept and force students to learn every
rule about that concept in three
separate times.
It's like it's a different language.
This way of writing things isn't just
counter-intuitive; its counter-mathematical
since rather than making
seemingly different facts look the same,
which is what math should do,
it takes three facts which should
obviously be the same
and makes them look artificially different.
Just think about how confusing
logarithms where
the first time that you learned about them.
This is of course a known issue
and the Internet has no shortage of people
raising the same concern with
suggestions for a better notation,
but recently I stumbled across a math
exchange post with the suggestion
so lovely, so symmetrical, so utterly
reasonable that I just have to share it.
For a relationship like 2 cubed equals 8,
take a triangle and write 2 in the lower left,
3 on the top and 8 on the lower right.
To express the operation 2^3,
remove that bottom right corner.
The symbol as a whole represents the
value that should go in the missing corner.
To express log₂(8),
which is asking the question
'2 to the what equals 8?',
remove the top number.
The symbol as a whole represents the
value that should go in the missing corner.
To express ∛8, which is saying:
'what number to the third power equals 8?',
remove the bottom left corner.
The symbol as a whole represents the value that should go in the missing corner.
In other words: all three operations are
completely symmetrically represented.
This triangle deserves a name and a
friend of mine at Khan Academy decided that
we should call it the triangle of power.
The definition alone is mildly pleasing
but where it gets fun is when you see
how much smoother all of the different
operations become.
In our current notation
there are six different ways to express
the various inverse operations.
Most of these are memorized as separate entities.
Some are barely even talked about.
And there's no discernible pattern,
even though all of them describe the same basic idea.
But students still have to spend
six times the effort to memorize each one,
are six times more
likely to make a mistake,
and have six separate opportunities to decide math is
dumb and boring and conducive to failure
and why don't I just go study art instead?
With the triangle of power,
all these operations follow the same pattern.
Our brains are really good at picking up
on patterns like this and you can much
more easily imagine a smooth mental
image associated with the property.
There's even kind of an aesthetic
pleasure to this and, who knows?
Maybe more of the artistically inclined
students would look favorably upon that
long enough to see just how valuable
their intuitions really are in the science.
Let's take another property, like the
idea that a^x * a^y = a^(x+y).
The corresponding fact for logarithms
is that log(xy) = log(x) + log(y)
When you write this with the triangle of power,
it's a little easier to see that both of
these expressions are really saying the same thing.
Remember: the symbol as a whole
represents the number at the missing corner,
so the top expression is saying that
when you multiply two numbers
that belong in the bottom right of the triangle,
it corresponds with adding the numbers
that belong to the top,
but that's also what the lower expression is saying:
when you multiply the numbers at the bottom right,
it corresponds with adding numbers that
belong to the top.
To help students with this,
you could draw inside of the triangle
saying that when the lower left is constant
the numbers at the top like to add,
while the bottom right numbers like to multiply.
What about when a different corner stays
constant, like the top?
Well in this case you'd write a
multiplication sign in both the bottom corners,
because with exponents and radicals
multiplication turns into multiplication.
The natural question that
a student might ask from here
is if there's an analogous rule for when the
lower right stays constant.
There is!
You have to introduce a new operation,
which for the sake of this video I'll call o-plus,
where a o-plus b equals 1 / (1/a + 1/b)
This is not actually a ridiculous thing to introduce,
since it comes up in physics all the time
like when you're computing parallel resistance.
With that symbol, you could say that
when the lower right number stays constant,
the top numbers like to get o-plussed together
and the bottom left numbers like to get multiplied.
This is actually a really nice
connection between logarithms and roots
and it never gets discussed;
probably because the notation isn't
really conducive to asking the question.
I could go on and on here, showing a lot
of other properties, but honestly I think
the best case I can make here is to
encourage you to explore it for yourself
and notice that just about everything
involving exponents, logs and radicals
becomes nicer when you use the triangle of power.
By the way, I hope that it goes without saying
that in this perfect world
students wouldn't learn these operations
purely from the symbols.
They should still ask why it's true
and why it doesn't follow a different pattern.
But the point is that when the notation
actually reflects the math,
the questions that students are most naturally asking
tend to be the ones that cut right into
the essence of what's going on.
The asymmetries in the notation correspond
with actual asymmetries
in the numerical relationship a^b=c itself,
not in the artificial asymmetries
of squiggles and words.
When a student asks why the top likes
to get added in one context, but o-plussed in another,
the teacher can point out the property that
reflecting the triangle reciprocates the top
and then they can start addressing
where that fact comes from.
My sincere hope is that
students don't learn by symbolic patterns
but by substantive reasoning
and rederivation within their own heads
but the fact is: most of us do first
learn things by symbolic manipulation,
so when there's an opportunity to
significantly speed up that process,
we should take it!
And if you agree with me that the triangle of power is clearly better than what we have already
start actually using it in your notes
to see what it feels like.
Spread the word and if you're a teacher
maybe start teaching this to your students
so that we can get them hooked
while they're young.